when I was young heaven was different I
thought oh you go to heaven the first
thing I thought about honestly was the
food I thought about the food because
you know if I'm going all of that way
and I'm dying to even get into the joint
they better have some entrees you're
fair man they better have a couple soup
du jour z' and douche mine maybe we all
better be having soup and that's the
first thing I thought about when I was a
child when I thought about heaven I
thought oh man they gotta have all the
different you know you have a breakfast
item right here and you have a little
over there you got an extra chocolate
area if you want to run through there
and get some chocolate or do that or
whatever you know I just thought they
have spare rib that kind of stuff I've
never even had spare rib that I'd heard
about it and sometime if you met like a
rich man or something like that when you
were young and you smelled his breath
you might catch that hit of Essar off
that bad boy I'm talking my spare rib
and you get that just oh okay I see what
y'all doing at home you know I got a
little bit of cash at the house but
that's what I thought about heaven when
I thought about heaven when I was a
child my heaven had all kind of they had
food they had a big table with food on
it and then what else sorry they had a
lot of clouds I remember my heaven it
was a cloudy heaven like and not like I
guess not like 70% chance of rain or
anything like that or it was overcast
but fluffy that was my idea of heaven
was overcast but fluffy and kind of warm
like probably clouds that were maybe you
know 400 count or 200 count or at least
80 count dude I got some pillows at home
that these bastards are probably about
four count you can feel the the quills
from the UM I don't even know what
animal it was it said it was goose but I
bet it's I bet it's a little bit more of
a Warbler it seemed like they plucked
about 2,000 Warblers and thirties it
these feathers into them pillow but
every you got a if you lay in one
position then that quill comes out and
gets you you got a turn it's like oh man
right then no no no and finally you get
in the right spot and you with no quills
and that's when you're like all hell
yeah and we're now we living now we're
living just laying in the Lord's lap
baby when you get that nice comfortable
pillow I can't believe people don't have
pillows installed around our head or
neck people get tattoos all the time oh
that's that ain't comfortable you just
you see somebody with a tattoo it's nice
its artistic its drawing but it isn't uh
you know it's not it's not comfortable
if I saw somebody got a pillow so sewn
into the back of their head come on boy
I'd be right look I would understand it
I say oh yeah I see what you doing there
that with you just got that big just
that that way anyway somebody even if
you fall down you had that nothing stay
down you trip over something stay down
you eat now you're napping there's
definitely a beauty I think of uh you
know I think there's just going to be
new things we're gonna start doing in
the future that we're not doing yet
where we're taking care you know you
know so a pillow to your head or you
know add uh maybe some piping or
something on the outside of our knees
and legs to give us more sturdy
people aren't that sturdy run run and
push someone I bet you they fall over
nine out of ten times if you run and
push somebody that batch is going down
but then change your game up change your
vibe up if the if they if they got you
know a couple of pieces of PVC pipe
hooked on each leg baby who knows what
could happen it might take you a half
hour to really bring them down to the
ground so anyway just kind of but but
what was your idea of heaven when you
were young you know what was it and what
is it now that's what I think now my
idea of heaven no emails no emails no
smart phones just dumb phones remember -
dumb phone do you remember the dumb
phone you did go over - it was making a
loud noise you did pick it up and
somebody would ask they got to ask for
one person this is a rendered er no and
you can lie here lie so easily you could
even if you were Randi you could be like
Randi ain't here oh you got the wrong
number we don't even have a random right
now let me see if Randy gets here Randy
nope being here I'm gonna happen with
the dumb phone you could anything the
dumb phone and also if you if you answer
you didn't want to talk somebody you
could wrap the cord it had a cord you
could wrap the cord around your neck tyo
el bruh take your own life right there
do you like damn man what happened to
Burt you like well somebody called he
couldn't handle it and now he's in
heaven but yeah that's my heaven no
email dumb phones only and what else
still food and I'm thinking now more
nachos more Chicken Picatta
maybe oh where else what else would I
have definitely still to dessert but
more of like I would go with a coconut
when I was young it could be anything
just sugar it could be a table full of
sugar I don't even care just let me
stick my head in it for about 19 seconds
you know I don't even care I don't mean
it I don't care if they just put a bunch
of Laffy Taffy under my tongue and
punched me right in the mouth you know
when you're young you don't care but now
when I'm older I want my heaven to be a
little bit more I don't know I guess I
just want different things in it I want
you know I definitely want a live one a
lot of people there and but honestly
dude if somebody's real chatty you could
dhm bro put them in a different heaven
because I mean when I go to heaven dude
I ain't doing a ton of listening okay I
want a quiet have been so if you don't
want to get a different heaven if they
got kind of a more urban heaven or
something then y'all can do that but my
I'm staying in that low just kind of
mild maybe a breeze the loudest thing is
a breeze you know maybe a breeze that
could sing so it's just kind of lonely
teardrops you know a breeze that kind of
just had could also you know know you
got that yeah yeah
the branches green beside me like I
don't want anything real loud in my
heaven but we'll see man and I want the
joy there too I want everything to be
Joy's I probably won't even be able to
judge when I'm in heaven now there won't
be in it as much judgment gosh that'd be
nice to have less judgment imagine
somebody's just imagined that that would
be really just the biggest piece in my
in my whole heart and brain if there was
less judgment inside of me because if
you crack me open dude you got about a
thousand Judy's fall out bro cuz I'm
judge mint I'm judge mint bruh I'm dude
if you saw me at a flavor fry scream I'm
judgmental it chip Papa I just it's hard
not to judge sometime you know it's hard
but but also the judgment of me allowed
me to be able to do stand-up comedy and
do comedies so there's
no it's as double swordman but but yeah
what was your heaven like now do you
have a different heaven and now I think
more there is when you're a kid a heaven
is just they got animals there but you
could pet him more I think they have
alligators but they're not dangerous you
might see alligator and he's you know if
you ask him if he's ever eaten like
human he would he would tell you but he
would he wouldn't just tell you in front
of her but he would kind of whisper to
you later or kind of write it on a you
know maybe you know on a napkin or
something or something give it slip it
to you say yeah I've had a little bit of
you know you know I'm saying I've had a
couple vietze about a river you feel me
I've had a couple ah a couple bad
batches came down by the water and I was
on ground but I think you know it's just
different now because what am I talking
about but I don't know um but yeah if
you have it what was your head did you
have a different heaven when you were
young as to what your heaven idea is now
you know now my heaven has more like
loved ones in it it's not just about
what I want it's more I think about a
little bit of you know there's other
people I want to make sure everybody you
know gets in you know a site I don't
know
anyway if you ever thought on what your
heaven was like as a child maybe if you
had an idea of heaven and if what it's
like now and some people you don't
believe in heaven that's fine you got
here working just kind of milling around
maybe that's it doesn't sound fun to me
I like more of like you know that's our
I'm a romantic you know I'm a romantic
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one